meet the robot chemist a mobile
autonomous worker that has been designed
to offer a helping hand around the lab
we started the project around three
years ago and we'd never worked with
mobile robots before we've worked with
automation but the first few months were
that were spend really just learning how
to drive the thing around the lab
reliably what we've done unusually is to
use a mobile system that has advantages
because you can really drop it into an
existing lab and without much
modification use equipment which is
already there to some extent if a human
can use the equipment the robot could
use the equipment this robot helper has
been designed by chemists at the
University of Liverpool to help them in
their research into developing photo
catalysts which are materials that help
produce hydrogen from water using lights
but the robot it communicates with a
software control system wirelessly it
needs to be wireless because it's moving
around a large space the robot weighs
out the solid catalyst it dispenses the
liquids it shines the lights onto the
samples it measures the outputs which is
nitrogen and based on this output the
hydrogen emission from the experiment it
then makes a decision about what to do
next just like a human chemist this
robot needs to be able to adapt its
workflow based on the outcome of its
experiments and this requires a
computational solution if you work out
the number of possible combinations of
the components in the experiment it's
something like 98 million so the robot
uses an optimization algorithm using a
method called Bayesian optimization to
navigate that chemical space to help it
work more like a human chemist this
optimization algorithm is a type of AI
that gives the robot decision-making
capabilities but unlike its human
counterpart the robot can run
continuously so there's a balance to be
struck between giving the robot too much
freedom and restricting it if you
explore too much then you end up doing
98 million experiments and that's just
not possible but if you exploit too much
if you optimize too greedily or too
quickly you don't necessarily find the
best solution during these experiments
the robot relies on its articulating arm
to interact with lab equipment and at
the end of this is a special gripper
that allows the robot to pick things up
and operate machinery to navigate the
lab and to avoid misplaced stools or
avoid collisions with its human
co-workers this robot uses lidar which
is a bit like radar but uses lasers
instead to map its reading' environment
on top of this laser scanning system
there's a a force feedback calibration
and what that is is the robot taps a
cube which is located in a fixed space
and that then provides a sixth position
reference point the robot is programmed
with the coordinates of equipment and
instruments that it needs to use and
each of these stations is marked with
their own cubes this gets the robot
closer to having the sort of positioning
and control that a human would have with
their hands which is essential when
interacting with delicate glassware it
doesn't just move around according to a
program it navigates and makes its a
choice to do the most optimal schedule
now you could in principle do that with
a human but it's a pretty uncomfortable
way for most people to work to be driven
by an algorithm bear in mind the robot
doesn't invent the experiment doesn't
design the experiment it doesn't come up
with the hypotheses so so the Robo is a
tool to search the space we still need
people to think of the problems to work
on so I don't see it as replacing jobs
at this stage I see it as augmenting
people's abilities to do research and
amidst the global pandemic the robot has
found compelling new potential in
maintaining lab work during periods of
social distancing we've now received a
lot of interest on a technology in terms
of how might you restart laboratories
while still operating a certain level of
social distancing if you have a
technology where you can load load the
system up
and then that takes three hours and then
it works for eight days or two weeks by
itself then you can see possibilities
there so yeah I'd be delighted if we can
find some way to
[Music]